speaking of useless there's a new rapper
new rapper coming up that's that's
coming for tom mcdonald's
crown tom mcdonald's got some some
competition
yeah this tom mcdonald this guy this
guy's name is burton
burton check it out dude it's pretty
dope whom i may concern
america's in distress with our future on
the line look around us a mess we took a
turn
now everything you say is offensive and
we slowly lose on our freedom ain't got
no defense
like stop speeding
but i don't know what i can say they
want to silence my voice taking
amendments away
nobody's silencing you sir yeah i hear
you but i i feel like a lot of these
guys confuse
people nobody like nobody knowing who
you are
with you being silenced it's not the
same thing
feel like communism out in l.a with 20
000 troops in dc gave them nowhere to
stay when donald trump left he left that
[ __ ] perfect in place but biden killed
thousands of jobs on his very first day
yeah that's crazy and i ain't even come
to preach no manga word but china's got
ships around
can i say something and those agree with
me forget what he's saying
he's a better rapper than tom mcdonald
i'm not saying he's good obviously but
he's a better
lyrically a better rapper than thomas i
suppose but
i'm still sick of this like i want my
rap to be about eating percocets
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know drop top
[ __ ]
hard top vehicles you know what i mean
shootouts like
let's keep this simple all right it's
it's like i don't want to hear
punk rock songs about
popping bottles and [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't want to hear
rap songs about politics like there's
just certain things that don't mesh to
me
i don't want to hear your political rap
i want to hear rap about [ __ ]
putting their ass cheeks in your face uh
a question that we ask every time this
or will smith
will smith smith though he was in
independence day
fair enough you're trying to go out like
that after all i've been through
my constitution died i just went and
bought me a suit see a sick home for the
girls patriots probably gonna shoot
i shouldn't address this but submitting
some dresses can now piss in the ladies
room with your teenage daughter but hey
equality right tell it to the future
victims all around he's kind of just
rapping memes isn't he
they're all that's all these guys do
it's another meme rapper they don't have
any real actual personalities
which is why they never really made it
so then they're like well i gotta blow
up i'm gonna do the trump thing
huh throughout the country life's about
to get harder
america's in distress with our future on
the line look around us
we took a turn shall we read the
comments
hey stop speeding stop rapping
first time listener not sorry i did keep
it up bro yeah
cool man from one creator another thank
you thanks for using your influence for
something right oh man
that's so cool no way with this ever
trend
but i'm 100 with you brother good [ __ ]
by the way i like the people that go you
know at least this guy's got a good
message listen you can have a good
message and still suck
right like i don't have to like this is
the whole thing that it goes back to the
thing i've been arguing for months for
years really
you got to stop rallying behind these
people just because you agree
politically
like that's how the griff begins that's
how that's the spirit of grifting is
you know hey hi i'm an artist you
otherwise wouldn't give a [ __ ] about
but since we both like trump like it's
like
dude stop you wouldn't like this if he
was rapping about
anything he could be rapping the same
exact song
but it could be about you know um
right and you'd be going [ __ ] this
degenerate commie [ __ ]
so stop pretending he's good just
because he agrees with you about the
orange man
it's just as cringe as when the left
does it it's
in business-wise it's just the market
that they're filling man that's all it
is it's a market that they're filling
the market's open and they're filling it
with their uh well crap or not
with their [ __ ] base rap uh
okay there's a good one him or marky
mark
with or without the funky button marky
mark really mark wahlberg over him
yeah because he'll never be as based as
mark wahlberg
because mark wahlberg beat up an asian
guy
don't come around me if you're chinese
or whatever
i'll break your [ __ ] eye sockets out
hey
do me a favor get the [ __ ] out of my
neighborhood okay we're trying to open
up a wall burgers here
[Laughter]
who wins in a fight mark wahlberg or
liam neeson
cleaning up the streets i feel like they
team up if anything
you you watch my six oh [ __ ] make sure
there's no sl
bastards behind me and i'll take care of
any black bastard to come through here
with me
they're doing the predator the hand
thing exactly
i got your back brother we're gonna make
this happen
remember something never forget mark
wahlberg could have single-handedly
stopped 911. he told us so
would you imagine if imagine a world
where marky mark got the role for
american history x
oh no huh you see this huh i mean it's
not welcome
yeah you know they're my [ __ ] house
if it was him that wouldn't be a
redemption arc he would just stay the
guy from the beginning of the movie
you know i look all i do is i hate
blacks
and i [ __ ] the ugly girl from the craft
oh sorry sir what were you saying
something about yourself yeah let's see
if i scored
everything you say is offensive and
you do know right that like right now
um it's probably not the best time to
declare war and show footage of this
like maybe
maybe let the heat die down a little bit
yeah
because this is just going to get used
against you and for the record
somebody's saying
uh forza bulk is hot she was hot
but she was still the ugly girl in the
craft
yeah i agree with you she just wasn't
the hottest chick in the
from the it's the craft
chick and then the other chick
um i can't even no i can't i could
i can only stand so much of this you
don't want war no i'd prefer if we
didn't
well we're gonna have war but it's gonna
be with iran can we send him and tom
mcdonald